florida governor ron desantis he
continues to deliver success
after success for the residents of the
great state of florida
he put an end of all emergency covert
restrictions schools
they've been open in florida for
in-person learning since august
restaurants they've been open since the
fall
florida safely reopened while protecting
seniors the entire time
big blue states failed suffered under
disastrous lockdown policies
that were pushed by let's see cuomo
murphy
whitmer wolf gavin newsom and it doesn't
stop there
florida is also prioritizing election
integrity
the governor signing into law a bill
that bans ballot harvesting enforces
voter id
limits the use of drop boxes addresses
concern about unsolicited mail-in
ballots
and that's not all florida also cracking
down on rioting enforcing law and order
supporting our brave men and women in
law enforcement with governor desantis
announcing a 1
000 pandemic bonus for all of florida's
first responders
meanwhile in new york they're defunding
the police a billion dollars in new york
city
launching vicious attacks on cops on a
daily basis
shooting you know shootings have
skyrocketed a whopping 86 percent
compared to 2020 a record year that was
double the number 2019
here to explain more florida governor
ron desantis
let's start with the state of emergency
and the oil and the gas shortage
governor
well sean uh this is something that's a
very serious attack on critical
infrastructure in our country
this pipeline actually doesn't touch
florida but it does feed into many of
our gas stations
so we've declared a state of emergency
we're lifting restrictions to be able to
get more fuel
into pumps but the bite administration
needs to take this seriously their
initial response is
oh this is a private pipeline and just
shrug your shoulders
this is important infrastructure for our
country and it could
impact our economy greatly if they don't
respond
five things i think are needed for voter
integrity and confidence voter id
common sense signature verification i
think that's common sense
chain of custody it's got to be
sacrosanct and we keep an eye on it
cleaning up voter rolls
and the law of statute says partisan
observers can observe both sides i think
that ought to be maintained and
respected
it wasn't in 2020. your thoughts
well sean we're very proud of what we
did in florida in 2020 you and i have
talked about it we counted 11 million
votes by midnight
very transparent and people had
confidence
in the results at the same time i don't
believe in standing pat
we go on offense we look forward to
heading off problems
fact is we can't have ballot harvesting
it's prone to fraud
we've got to have voter id enforced
strictly
we're doing that in the state of florida
another thing we did which is very
important
we banned these third-party private
groups from spending millions of dollars
to actually administer
elections like zuckerberg did they call
him them zuckerbucks
we have banned zuckerbucks in the state
of florida so we're proud of what we did
in 2020
we believe the strength of this package
is such that we're going to
also be strong in 22 and in 24.
how come your schools in florida now i
remember interviewing you early on
when the pandemic struck you used every
state agency
and you instructed them to protect the
elderly which you have a very high
elderly population in florida
that turned out to be the the wisest
decision of any governor in the country
and there were a few others to their
credit that did the same thing we saw
what happened
when they didn't do that you were able
to get schools open in august you were
able to keep restaurants open
why couldn't these other governors
follow your lead
well i think they embraced fair failed
policies sean which
last march and april okay this is a new
thing
but man the data came in by the end of
april
and they should have reversed course
they didn't we've had schools in person
as you've said
we had a successful school year it's
coming to a conclusion over the next
couple of weeks
and we're proud of that but just think
of all the millions of kids who were
locked out of school
for over a year in places like
california
that is going to have ramifications for
our society for years and years
and i can't tell you sean every time i
go out someone will come up to me and
say
thank you for keeping us open you saved
my job
or you saved my business and we know if
we were in other states like california
and new york
i know my job would be gone or i know my
business would be gone
so we're proud of the success that we've
had uh we obviously have more to do
going forward but uh
the damage of those lockdowns are gonna
reverberate in this country for a long
time
yeah um your support for the police you
know it was kind of refreshing to see
one state at least recognize the hard
work that they do every day
something you can afford how is it all
these states have
you know less population even than your
state but you have
half the budget size that they do and
better infrastructure
just trying to figure out the math that
won't happen income tax
and new york has over twice the budget
we do and we have millions of more
people
than they do and so we're proud of the
way we've managed it it's given us an
ability
to do some things like provide these law
enforcement bonuses sean
they have a tough job they were treated
horribly in many parts of the country
for the entire year we've stood by them
in florida 100 percent
but we also recognize this was a very
challenging year
so this is one way for us to say thank
you another way the bill that you
mentioned our annie rioting bill
provides additional support for the
police and it says very simply
the local government tries to defund law
enforcement the state of florida will
veto that we will make sure law
enforcement's funded and if people are
rioting if they're damaging property
attacking police
they are going to go to jail and we're
going to stand by the men and women in
uniform
you might be seeing me more often in
florida in case you've been reading in
the news
just saying uh well sean i i told you
the driver's license can be minted very
quickly so you just got to give me a
call
we'll get that done and we'll also be
happy to register they're going to
accuse me of then getting special
favoritism treatment i'll go the hard
route i'll fight the
the dmv thank you governor some breaking
hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else